i'm sam levine i'm here with a film ali
KU booster versus the Nazis and you can
follow me on twitter i'm at sanmina-sci
mmm Olivia angel
how does have involved are there that is
a good question I became involved with
this project years before it actually
came to fruition so Damon Lindelof of
lost name wrote this as a one-act play
that he submitted as a writing sample to
get a job on national riches a long long
time ago and then it was so good this is
short that people said am relish
produced us and so many years after that
is associate professor Noreen finally
got everything together to make this
don't happen and we're going to shoot it
I think three years ago ready four years
ago now in New York I had me I think we
can Lainie Kazan who's in the film and a
couple other people lined up and then
it's like that second of fun party and
we all thought it was went over a year
ago I got the call hey we're actually
going to make the film here in LA are
used to enjoy some class of course the
bedrock and so we shot at last January I
think for februari here in LA Lainie
Kazan George single what Chris Hemsworth
also known as a Thor great cast so funny
and here we are
take a different challenges you're right
now it is i'm personally basic right now
so it's it's tough right now there's so
many there's a lot fewer films being
made then there used to be say even two
or three years ago the common is heard
in pacifica on the recovered from the
writers strike weird so what's happening
is because of our culture is being made
let's say there were a hundred and fifty
features Studio features being made
three years ago now there's a little
like 95 and so with your features being
made a big-time actress are doing TV and
so a big-time actor through TV now
middle-class TV actors like me not how
much work to go around space tub I'm
seeing a lot of guys on auditions now
have mercy auditions or that I'm
thinking to myself by your audition I
mean I don't want to go into names out
there but I saw Chris growing at an
audition for a TV show which I'm not
saying it's nothing against semanas
talent is obviously tells guy belongs in
their features television that the fact
that he is willing to audition just
proves how hard it is out there there
are a coppers flying out against a lot
of actors and now everyone's kind of
fighting for the same job